[Applaudissements]
bonsoir un matin
veillée avec l'esprit complètement
embrumé êtes assis sur un banc seul
comme si vous faisiez une renaissance
devant vous vous voyez l'opéra et vous
fait la relation comme quoi vous êtes à
paris mais vous sentez que quelque chose
ne va pas vous examinez vous êtes
habillé d'un petit blouson vous avez des
pâtes à l'intérieur au pied un corner en
plastique attachés à votre ceinture une
alliance à votre doigt mais presque
instantanément
vous ne savez plus qui vous êtes on est
plus aucune mémoire de votre vie ça me
rappel man in black
tu sais tu sais plus c'est flippant
eh ben c'est ce qui m'est arrivé à moi
il ya 30 ans j'étais complètement perdu
je sentais mauvais est à la recherche de
mon identité je fouille mes poches
je fouille montcornet j retire quelques
objets des pièces de monnaie un ticket
de métro un plan de paris un crayon un
petit carnet mais comme si je prenais
ces objets à un autre comme s'ils
n'appartenaient pas et jouve quand même
ce carnet par curiosité et je reconnais
immédiatement que c'est le monde
d'écriture j'avais écrit avoir été à
moudre au bord de la seine à d'autres
endroits dans paris et je me souvenais
déjà pu et une phrase qui me glace le
sang surtout n'oublie pas d'écrire je me
suis écrit ça dans mon passé déjà oublié
et la cheville angoisse qui monte
je me sens complètement vidé
complètement perdu et du coin de l'oeil
j'avais quand même remarqué une cabine
téléphonique et ayant des patins ok je
me suis fait plus de sorties pour
quelqu'un m'appelle le téléphone va
retentir et ça va me réveiller de ce
cauchemar et je décide de rester dans
cette cabine
la sonnerie alem réveiller et c'est pas
la sonnerie qui me réveille mais des
policiers pour un contrôle d'identité
l'identité de qui
et oui de me sentir rassurés je me sens
comme un graissée et je vais leur
échapper il me rattrape rapidement
pistolet sur la tempe menottes me jette
dans une camionnette
les directions de poste de police le
plus proche hélas un interrogatoire
doit-on dire pressants ils me disent
qu'ils m'avaient repérée depuis
plusieurs jours et rend dans le coin il
me demande pourquoi j'étais parti quand
ils vont ils ont voulu ai demandé qui
j'étais et il me demande qui je suis et
à toutes leurs questions la seule chose
que je suis capable de leur dire je ne
sais pas qui je suis je sais pas qui je
suis il trouve qu'il ya quelque chose
qui ne va pas bien et ils téléphonent
aux préfets qui décident de mots spitz
alizés pour me protéger
maudite ont alors me protéger de qui
peut-être pour protéger les autres parce
qu'un inconnu
ça fait peur on sait pas est ce qu'il
est bon est ce qu'il est mauvais et je
me retrouve hospitalisé d'office à
l'hôpital psychiatrique sainte anne de
paris
la porte se referme sur moi je fus mis
dans les mains d'infirmiers et de
médecins qui ont examiné sous toutes les
coutures et qu'ils s'aperçoivent que
j'ai un gros hématome à la nuque et je
passe d'autres examens que je ne connais
pas il déshabille une douche il m'a fait
bleu d'un pyjama bleu trop grand pour
moi et il me donne des cachets alors
des cachets dont on vient de
passer une camisole chimique et de l'art
des jours ou des semaines se passe où je
suis au milieu d'eux de plein de gens
que je perçois comme étant des faux et
que je refuse de côtoyer
je suis pas fou je ne suis pas fou mais
de jour en jour j'ai l'impression de
devenir un fou parmi ces fous on me
grave de médicaments j'ai l'impression
que personne ne s'occupe de moi sur orge
occupe mes journées à écrire il a
dessiné avec une imprimerie l'impression
étrange que je suis tout le temps
surveillé
j'ai l'impression qu'on me vole mes
dessins qu'on me vole mes écrits j'en
arrive à un point où mes médicaments que
je refusais jusque maintenant devienne
ma nourriture préférée et le x inscrits
sur ma boîte de médicaments fini par
devenir mon nom monsieur x
je reprends espoir quand même quand un
professeur vient me voir pour me dire
que sans que je le sache
il s'occupe de moi depuis pas mal de
temps et qui peut me dire que je souffre
d'une amnésie et me rassure en me disant
que ça se soigne à la vue de tous les
écrits il pense que j'ai pu faire des
aides des études supérieures et à la vie
me les a peut-être même une formation
artistique
mais ce dont il est certain est ce que
vous entendez ce soir par mon accent et
certaines expressions comme patins ou
cornet qui sont typiquement leur haine
il est certain que je viens de l'est de
la france et ils aimeraient bien creuser
tout ça avec moi et on propose des
séances de narcose je fais une petite
aparté les narcos ce sont des injections
de sérum de vérité qui est dit pas
totale qui était déjà très controversé à
l'époque qui m'attend est totalement
interdit parce que ça lui le cerveau
mais dut qu'à l'époque j'avais déjà côte
montgrillet puis au prof
vas-y mon gros on ira et il a fallu
attendre la troisième narcose pour que
je me réveille enfin devant un
professeur qui avait un large sourire
les indices de l'est étaient confirmés
et un prénom singulier ressurgi de mon
passé ou non subconscient a attiré toute
son attention et il me demande de
prendre patience selon me demander de
prendre patience à moi même pas en rêve
j'ai l'impression qu'on me demande
encore de perdre du temps comme s'il en
est passé perdu par deux questions mais
je patiente quand même et jusqu'au jour
où je suis appelé dans le bureau du
professeur et à la couverture du
bourgeois un prof encore une fois tout
sourire et à ses côtés un inconnu qui se
lève à mon arrivée vient vers moi
les bras tendus morlaàs douloureusement
zen mec-là est aigri mais qu'est ce que
tu fous là vieux port où je suis
charlelie on a fait l'école des
beaux-arts ensemble à nancy je m'excuse
mon pote mais je me souviens tu de ton
prénom et ton nom est inquiète
inquiet dossier scolaire hop là les
anciens élèves on va te retrouver avoir
trouvé ta famille tes sauver mon pote tu
est sauvé et ce beau mec charlie avant
de le quitter
nature de son amitié de faire tout le
nécessaire pour m'aider vous rendez
compte quand même que sans ce prénom
atypique ressurgi de mon passé au de mon
subconscient pendant cette narcose
charlelie sans la notoriété et la
gentillesse ou dévouement des revenus de
ce chanteur nancéen charlélie couture
je serai peut-être encore aujourd'hui à
sainte anne si dans l'art court j'avais
dit les prénoms communs comme didier ou
pascal le prof n'y aurait même pas prêté
attention
voyez comme point le cerveau et
étrangers la mémoire mystérieuse et là
j'attends des jours une bonne nouvelle
je guette la porte je suis sûr que
quelqu'un va rentrer pour venir me
chercher je souhaite retrouver un jour
j'étais en train de manger un affirmé qu
une tape sur l'épaule que très pudique
où monsieur x dans un musée un succès
bien dit t'es retrouvé ton pote charline
il a bien bossé
tu t'appelles jacques michel jacques
michel duret allait bien avec moi dans
le petit salon le prof qui attend avec
ta femme et tes parents d'un coup
d'accueillir ça avec joie c'est plutôt
une angoisse que je ressens et je suis
infirmière un peu comme un zombie là
vers mon passé est arrivé dans le petit
salon le prof me prends pas le drapeau
pas que je tombe est en face de moi je
vois un couple de personnes âgées
enfin je déconne il avait même âge que
moi maintenant donc aux corbeaux jeune
quand mais voilà dans les yeux de qui je
pouvais voir de la tristesse
de la peur mais à côté d'eux une petite
brunette pas dieu qu'on me présente
comme étant ma femme jiwok j'avais bon
goût dans les yeux de qui je voulais
voir de la joie et de l'espoir mais le
gros problème que j'avais c'était moi je
ne faisais que de lire que dans des yeux
d'étrangers mon coeur est évident
je suis ta maman je suis ton papa je
suis ta femme les enfants sont restés à
la maison rajoute des gosses en
plus je regarde les photos c'est toi
bébé avec ton frère à la maison tout en
communion à l'armée at-on mariage avec
ta femme avec des enfants non des gens
inconnus des photos vide de sens pas le
propos - tant dans les poumons et on
arrête la séance et le lendemain ou
peut-être quelques jours plus tard on
explique complètement troublé et le
professeur me prend immédiatement en
main et meurent montre des photos qui
avaient été laissées il me dit que mon
trouble est normal mais tu vu les photos
c'est bel et bien ma famille c'est pas
une hallucination et que ces gens-là et
batterie bientôt ils vont venir me
chercher pour que je revive avec eux et
c'est avec eux que j'ai retrouvé ma
mémoire qui va peut-être se passer
un déclic qui met en selle que ça de
mémoire qu'on appelle peut-être l'effet
des plis de madeleine comme l'a si bien
écrit proust grâce à un bruit et l'odeur
et paf je retrouverai toute ma vie
géniale mais à l'hôpital
tout le monde s'amuse maintenant à
m'appeler jacques michel jacques michel
jacques michel mais ce nouvel inconnu
qui est dans mon corps mais pas encore
dans mon coeur me fait peur je reste
toujours monsieur x et des photos avait
été laissé pour moi et ils deviennent
mes devoirs quotidiens
un infirmier avait été proposée pour me
les montrer comme compte en regard d'un
jeu de 7 familles il fallait que je dise
qu'ils étaient sur les photos dans la
famille intel dans la famille aurait
fallu que je vous donnais le père la
mère le frère l'enfant et c est un bon
jour
on m'amène enfin des vêtements propres
en me disant que c'est le grand jour et
emmène dans le petit salon et là je vois
le professeur tout souriant aimé
inconnus qui sont là tu parles si les
sourires vient de leur donner mon mode
d'emploi pour kim embarque avec lui pour
me reconstruire sans même s'occuper s'il
manquait une pièce on se dirait un peu
chez qui a le truc
la porte se referme sur moi pour laisser
partir avec ceux qui sont les miens et
on arrive après une longue route dans ma
maison qu'on fait visiter que je
reconnais pas et les jours suivants on
me présente en vrai tous ces gens que
j'avais appris à reconnaître sur les
photos mais tout ce genre sont pour moi
des étrangers me font peur aussi bien
mes parents que mes enfants que les amis
je ne ressens rien pour eux et là je me
sens de nouveau complètement perdu tout
ce ca connus inconnus me font peur mais
la petite brunette qui dit être ma femme
me rassure et je veux absolument lui
faire confiance
je sais que tous ces inconnus ne voulais
que mon bien il voulait que je reprenne
ma vie en oubliant que j'avais oublié il
voulait retrouver celui que j'étais
avant celui qu'ils aimaient mais moi mon
côté c'était pas prêt j'avais le
sentiment que je devais me reconstruire
par rapport à mes propres sentiments et
non pas par rapport aux sentiments des
autres
je ne me rendais pas compte de l'amour
qui me donnaient je ne m'en rendais pas
compte qu'en refusant mon handicap je
finissais par les handicapés
et j'en dis là c'est plus d'un et je me
suis retrouvé de plus en plus seul
j'étais englué simplement dans mon
amnésie que l'on avait défini comme
étant une amnésie identitaire c'est une
amnésie rétrograde excessivement lourdes
est heureusement très rares on serait
que quelques-uns au monde à en souffrir
mais heureusement pour moi je n'avais
pas d'autre amnésie tels que amnésie
antérograde ou procédurale et j'avais
gardé une très très grande partie de mes
acquis mais malgré ça trois années se
sont écoulées stérile juste a occupés à
rechercher mon passé sans donner d'amour
sans rien l'alcool était même devenu mon
ami et martin s'est rendu compte de mon
désarroi et un soir elle maintenant de
m'asseoir devant elle elle me dit je
vois que c'est dur pour toi chérie
mais ça ce que seul lui aussi pour nous
arrête de regarder tout le temps
derrière toi je te propose qu'ensemble
on aille de l'avant
et là je ne suis pas citée par pudeur ou
par les nazis en face qui tenteraient
quand même à prouver que j'étais pas
amnésiques de partout le ventre de
martin s'est mis à grossir elle m'invite
à le toucher
elle invite nos deux enfants à le faire
aussi et c'est à ce moment là que j'ai
eu un un déclic ou nouvelle étincelle
que mes sentiments se sont réveillés la
petite brunette dont jouit pas du tout à
l'heure est devenu vraiment ma femme
l'enfant qui était dans son ventre était
déjà bien
j'acceptais mes parents comme étant les
mains et j'ai accepté tout le reste de
la famille amis comme étant bien
et voilà le troisième enfant est venu au
monde
ça c'était de la joie mais le temps et
la mort m'ont enlevé mes racines mon
père et ma mère avant même que j'aie eu
le temps de les connaître
j'aimerais bien aujourd'hui pouvoir
téléphoner à ce naufragé qui était moi
là bas dans cette cabine téléphonique
complètement paumé comme ce soir sur la
scène pour lui dire d'arrêter de perdre
du temps de faire souffrir et de
souffrir mais on ne peut pas revenir en
arrière
alors il est temps que je vous présente
celle qui a été et qui est toujours mon
étincelles
notre petite brunette qu'elle a bien ma
puce
les monts et à celle d'inspiration et
c'est grâce au courage et à l'amour de
mes proches que je suis là ce soir c'est
grâce à martin c'est martin qui m'a
appris à aimer à mémé à redevenir un
père à votre venir à marie à reprendre
ensemble un nouveau chemin de vie et
construire de nouveaux projets voilà
trente ans ont passé et on a là
aujourd'hui heureux pour partager avec
vous pour vous dire simplement qu'une
petite étincelle peut éclairer tout un
chemin de vie merci martin verser off
[Applaudissements]